normal quand vous êtes ce que l'on
appelle un aventurier de l'extrême vous
avez descendu l'amazone à la nage vous
avez fait le tour du monde par
l'équateur le tour du cercle polaire à
contrevent est à contre courant bref
tout ce que vous faites semblait
impossible en fait il a qu'une chose qui
semble toujours impossible avec vous
c'est raconter votre vie en moins de 15
minutes nous essaierons de le faire à 20
heures
[Musique]
michael gambon soir vous êtes né le 16
juillet
1966 à johannesbourg en afrique du sud
d'une famille afrikaner père directeur
d'un lycée privé mère enseignante alors
très jeune vous toucher à tous les
sports le rugby le cricket l'athlétisme
le tennis le vélo et à l'âge de 8 ans un
jour vous prenez votre vélo pour
rejoindre la ferme de votre oncle à 300
km de là j'ai pas disais à mon père que
je valais visiter cet oncle à g je
disais que je veux visiter un oncle et
il a eu deux frères avait un frère qui
avait été à 10 km et au caire qui a
habité à 300 km et lui pensé
naturellement je vais aller visiter
son frère qui a dit qu'il aimait bien
sûr à l'âge de 13 ans votre père vous
amène sur la côte ouest de l'afrique du
sud là où s'élève une statue de grands
explorateurs vasco de gama et quand vous
arrivez vous vous dites c'est ce que je
veux faire en fait j'étais assis sur les
rochers et puis je voyais je voyais les
bateaux passer j'imagine et déjà d'être
un fait sur les bateaux comme ça et puis
là je dis mais il faut il faut y aller
alors l'âge de 18 ans vous intégrer
l'armée les forces spéciales
sud-africaine fait la guerre de namibie
à 21 ans vous reprenez vos études vous
apprenez amélioré les performances des
athlètes
et parallèlement vous commencez à
travailler avec votre oncle dans
l'import export de fruits et légumes et
vous faites rapidement fortune là dedans
grâce à une affaire de chou quand tu
regardes trop vite trop via notre vie
tout court je me revient en dix ans mais
je n'ai pas besoin d'y aller bosser j'ai
tout ce que je veux mais en fait je
pensais que j'ai eu tout ce que je
voulais et puis en fait j'ai eu rien et
puis c'était la liberté que je voulais
voilà en fait vous n'avez pas vraiment
de but précis dans la vie vous avez une
envie irrépressible de bouger et à 24
ans vous décidez de partir et là avant
de partir vous faites une grande fête
avec votre famille et vos amis et
vouloir donner tout ce que vous possédez
c'est-à-dire voitures maisons argent
vous donner tous il vous reste un sac à
dos et vous partez vous allez à
l'aéroport de johannesburg et à l'époque
il faut se souvenir que les seuls pays
qui accepte et des sud africains sans
visa c'était israël l'angleterre et la
suisse la suisse le premier vol par pour
tel aviv ya plus de place et vous partez
donc en suisse et vous vous retrouvez à
zurich vous arrivez là bas donc
étrangers en suisse avec 50 francs en
poche alors les premiers temps sont
extrêmement difficile évidemment vous
dormez dans les étables sous les pompes
chapardait des fruits vous voler à
l'étalagé par vous finirez par vous
intégrez donc et même pas rencontré katy
une néo zélandaise qui vit en suisse qui
deviendra votre femme et la mère de vos
filles alors vous allez 25 ans quand
vous débutez votre carrière
d'aventuriers avec ça c'est juste une
mise en bouche un si la traversée des
andes péruviennes en raft et en
parapente mais votre première grande
expédition c'est en 1997 vous allez 31
ans vous traverser l'amérique du sud à
pied sans assistance et vous montez au
mont miss me quel endroit où l'amazone
prend sa source à 5800 mètres et là vous
redescendez le fleuve quand même énorme
il redescend l'amazone depuis la source
jusqu'à l'océan atlantique ça fait quand
même 6700 km en hydrospeed pour elle
c'est que 7000 km 6 pas trop loin
si on fait un petit bout tous les jours
où on avance bien et puis qui était
important c'était que les gens me
demandaient souvent mike mais qu'est ce
que tu vas manger comment tu peux porter
autant de la norme de nourriture avec
toi mais en fait c'était j'apporte et
que la connaissance et puis la
connaissance de quoi manger quoi pas
manger ou n'aviez vous dites les
crocodiles qui mesurait moins d'un mètre
cinquante
je les mange et ceux qui mesurait plus
risquer de me manger donc je ne touchais
pas
[Applaudissements]
alors ça va durer cent dix sept jours et
un jour vous arrivez dans les estuaires
de l'amazone
mais c'est très très large de l'amazone
donc 7 321 km large field plus grand que
la suisse est là pour rejoindre la côte
vous avez dû nager l'équivalent de la
traversée de la manche quand même ouais
si tu continues de nager pendant deux
semaines juste pour retrouver la berge
pour rentrer à la maison mais
l'expédition était finie alors la
deuxième grande expédition c'est le tour
du monde mais en suivant de l'équateur
c'est quand même 40 mille kilomètres
alors sans engin motorisé vous y tenez
absolument à vous partez du gabon sur un
voilier et c'est la première fois que
vous vous retrouvez seul sur un voilier
ça vous empêche pas de traverser
l'atlantique jusqu'au brésil ouais moi
je dis toujours on n'est pas plus cons
que les autres c'est les autres arrivent
pourquoi pas moi a créé on en a toujours
en fait on a souvent peur de pertes et
river city c'est des gens nous parlent
souvent et puis c'est parce que si tu as
peur de père tu vas jamais gagnée comme
envie de gagner peut devenir plus plus
grande et plus fort que la peur de
perdre que tu peux y aller faire des
choses là quand même c'est terrible
parce que vous vous rencontre évidemment
la jungle en traversant l'amérique du
sud
les guérilleros les narcotrafiquants
enfin il n'y a pas que le danger
physique et aussi les rencontres que
vous faites en gîte vous passez en asie
et dans l'océan indien au sud du sri
lanka vous tombez sur une tempête avec
des vagues de 15 mètres et des ventes à
180 km/heure vous rester enfermé deux
jours dans votre cabine parce que y'a
rien à faire et vous avez cette phrase
formidable au début on a peur de mourir
et puis après on a peur de ne pas mourir
imagine 48 heures tout d'autre part en
seconde on s'est sauvé pour sauver des
bateaux sortis de l'eau des activités 24
heures sur 24 ou 48 heures et puis après
tu dis mais maintenant je ferme tout et
puis on verra deviennent que pouvoir
vous avez en afrique il ya d'abord le
kenya ensuite le lac victoria
hélas quand même sur la victoria ya un
orage vous dites c'était limite là quand
même j'étais stupide s'est pris un
bateau en bois je me angoisse dessus et
puis là il faut traverser la deuxième
plus grande lac simon 3 6 km et puis je
partis avec mon bateau je voyais nuages
noirs qui arrivait je dis oh oui là je
suis vraiment un peu dans la merde mais
moi je dis je suis toujours dans la
merde mais c'est que la profondeur qui
varient voyez un peu plus de moi et puis
j'ai commencé les premières vingt gars
entrer dans les bateaux j'ai essayé de
vider des bateaux du deuxième vague
couler et puis je me retrouvais avec 150
km à nager jusqu'à la berge alors là
vous passez au zaïre et quand vous
arrivez au zaïre vous tombez sur des
militaires rebelles et ils vous disent
bon ben voila tu sera fusillé demain à
5h du matin il là au moment d'être
fusillé il ya le mec qui devant vous
avec sa kalachnikov et vous avancez vers
lui sans avoir peur en l'insultant et ça
marche j'ai rien à perdre maintenant il
va me tuer si je prends la fusée jeu
mais compte ma tête et j'ai des tirs
et ce qui va le faire il l'a pas fait et
l'a pas fait voilà ensuite si le gabon
alors là vous faites 200 km par jour en
vélo pour rejoindre votre point de
départ et vous avez bouclé le tour du
monde par l'équateur sans engin motorisé
la troisième grande expédition c'est le
tour du cercle polaire arctique
mais contre les vents et contre les
courants quand on vous dit mais pourquoi
vous l'avez fait pourquoi contre les
vents et contre les courants il dit en
cas de réussite dans un sens plus
favorable
j'aurais passé ma vie à me demander si
j'étais capable de le faire dans l'autre
sens oui pourquoi pas préparé pour faire
un truc à 100% ouais et pas 90 peut
justement les dames mnr justement malc
pendant l'expédition préparatoire à ce
tour du cercle polaire donc vous allez
au bonheur à pied en solitaire vous
gelez les mains parce qu'à un moment
vous enlevez vos moufles pour refaire un
lacet vous avez les mains tellement
gelée que vous les mettez dans le feu
sur votre et chaud ouais et ça commence
à sentir la radio la viande de communes
barbe qui ont un peu et puis tu sont
rien
et tu t'en coup j'ai senti l'odeur de
viande de viande brûlée jeudi mais ça va
pas c'est comme ça
ça c'était le voyage préparatoire voilà
alors ensuite c'est le vrai voyage dont
vous partez en bateau du cap nord vers
le groenland
là vous tombez sur un tronc d'arbre qui
évidemment il ya un mètre d'eau dans le
bateau les icebergs ensuite vous
traversé le groenland 800 km de banquise
en solitaire et puis à un moment vous
êtes obligés de faire un détour
et le détour c'est pas rien c'est 1200
km ça a duré quatre mois alors que
normalement sur l'a10 durer sept jours
et vous l'avez fait à pied un ep en plus
sur la route migratoire des ours
polaires ce que vous racontez ce quand
on voit un ours ou faire des gestes
comme ça c'est bon à savoir
la part de banques comme ça ils ouvrent
la gueule les aurait comme sa grande et
puis c'est sûr qu'ils sont pas
dangereuses il veut juste montrer qu'ils
sont là et puis tout ce que tu dois
faire si tu dois tu dois marcher
vraiment éloigné tepa
thema qui voit que t'es d'humains qui
n'est pas une faute mais si nous arriver
rires il tente sais c'est pas de vent
dans la glace il approchait pattes
arrière il se mettre en boule comme ça
ib sonné il tire ses oreilles en arrière
latéral la toiture
écrire dessus si quand il commence des
grandes c'est dans il me manque un tigre
en cédant c'est irréversible
c'est celle attaques et alors il fait
moins 60 degrés quand vous avez votre
nez la nuit sur le sac de couchage il
fait tellement froid que le matin quand
vous vous levez vous arracher la peau du
nid qui reste accroché au sac parce
qu'elle a fait en respirant
bien mais d'un militaire qui qui sortent
des people parce qu'il fait moins 40 à
l'intérieur la tente c'est là où tout
gel autour du visage parce que je perde
environ en didot justin respirant la
nuit avant dormir je fonde la glace je
boire environ 6 litres d'eau
s'y vidéo me permet de rêver chaque deux
heures et chaque 2 or je fais pipi dans
mon sac de couchage dans un goûter avec
l'entrée un peu grande comme ça aux
règles si c'est les mecs ça se monte
encore
hélas youri d'enquêté est il utilisé
comme source que shana à et ses sources
de chaleur c'est pour
pauvres les pions chauffée du doigt de
pied les malines et vise aurait qui
exposait toujours froid alors ensuite il
ya les l'escale détroit de béring la
russie alors en russie vous marchez ça
c'est extraordinaire il traverse en
marchant sur le gazoduc de gazprom donc
là on sait ça va tout droit c'est bien
sauf qu'à des moments il ya quinze
mètres en dessous parce que le gazoduc
lui il suit pas
il ya le ramon les russes vous oblige à
faire 50 km en camion lyonnais en camion
et quand ils arrivent au bout de ces 50
km et du nord j'ai promis de le faire
sans engin motorisé il refait les 50 km
dans l'autre sens il revient au point où
les russes l'avaient amené c'est sur le
marché presque 1000 kilomètres près
tri chez moi je peux pas vivre avec ça
j'ai triché
la distance puis à la fin j'ai j'étais
pas si t'es pas en aide si tu triches du
parti
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui vous vivez en suis donc avec
votre femme et vos deux filles et vous
avez un projet donc qui est de faire
faire le tour du monde en voilier à des
jeunes je pense qu'on doit donner
l'espoir aux jeunes et puis l'idée
c'était de l'amener avec moi et puis de
le montrer
les plus belles places qui existe en
fait sur la terre dans chaque aliment et
puis pas de la montrer tout ce qu'on a
détruit tous les nains tout ce qui est
pas bien et puis si tu te montre la
beauté et la tue les shops en travers de
leur émotion et puis si ça qui veut
protéger et puis aujourd'hui j'ai vu je
rentrais d'une expédition de cinq 5 ans
j'ai vu ma femme 30 jours 25 ans et pour
ça ça marche
mais en fait directement de partager
toutes mes expériences avec les jeunes
on a 400 projets autour du monde c'est
peut-être du projet environnementale des
plus grandes au monde où on replante les
corail reprendre les arbres dans amazon
ont nettoyé des plages où on remarque la
plastique et dans la mer pendant je
parle il ya mes jeunes partout au monde
qui est en train de travailler pour
améliorer leur futur ya un site
vraiment mal les fonds donnés voilà
voilà voilà voilà voilà est ce que j'ai
essayé de vous marier successivement
l'état henri guaino aymeric carmela là
franchement là là là là là voilà déjà
mariées mais oui en plus de 30 jours
tous les cinq autres
merci de votre témoignage
des corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un pouce
bleus